here's a peek at what guests had to say
after the show okay we're back on the
Internet
Kareem should college athletes be paid
yes
that's bad yeah again that seems pretty
obvious at this point right I mean it's
it's been a slowly building issue but if
I feel like the momentum now they've
been exploited for years for years yeah
and and you know maybe if they paid them
it would also make them learn a little
more because I feel like they get a so
that's the deal is that we don't pay you
and you don't have to study right yeah
then they go right to the NBA and screw
up right often they do yeah cuz they
don't know the game right yeah I don't
know if you noticed in the NC tour this
year Wisconsin was not as athletic as
the rest of the teams but they were
competitive because they understood the
game they were very well coached that's
why they went as far as they did if they
had some athletic talent they probably
would won the whole thing right
six-time MVP remind you can't
six rings let's pretend he's not here
who's the greatest Bill Russell Kareem
abdul-jabbar or Michael Jordan I mean
that's it yeah yeah I'm on it yeah
LeBron well he's career isn't over yeah
we don't know we'll see but yeah all
right do you think Republicans are smart
to escalate the issue of Benghazi before
the elections I don't but you know maybe
maybe they'll find something there they
haven't yet enough it's crazy right I
mean I they thought this week they had
this smoking gun and I hear all the
people on Fox News a smoking gun smoking
gun smoking gun and then and what is it
what is it there's just never any there
there yeah no it's absurd I mean it and
it's interesting isn't it I mean it's
this last week the obsession of the
bomber care seemed to wane a little bit
and they went back to the old golden
oldie Benghazi Benghazi but which shows
a you know the defensive but they might
at least you would think that at least
they would want to be politically smart
they must read the polls that show
Americans made up their mind on this
alone don't even know what the hell it
is still work by we're doing yeah we do
know what it is it must have worked
before wide it is a strategy of do you
don't even know what it is you know the
story right yeah well I watch American
politics I yeah I mean the game of
politics that they know what works for
their people and the voters and they
just keep repeating the same tactics
over over that's my question is that
this is not working with the voters and
never has so why are they handcuffing
themselves to this dead hooker revenues
you're catering to their base which is
what politics has turned into now
everything is about getting that base
out there do I care about Benghazi I
think something happened but honestly I
care about the economy and I think
everyone who tries to defer you into
these other issues is wasting your time
and wasting my time something did happen
but everything that bad happens in the
world is not Obama's fault
or Hillary Hillary Clinton's fault this
is that two hats right that's exactly
this one's it's current and future but
eisah is is subpoenaing john kerry who
wasn't even in the State Department when
it happened
yes what is the purpose of that I mean
it's the worst grandstanding yeah it's
the minutes and now they have their own
Twitter website the whole thing it's
just a joke all right yeah all right
how will California position itself to
continue to create jobs the way it did
in the past invest in our growth engines
education infrastructure open really I
think this one came from your press
secretary I take that back I do
recognize the name yeah yeah there's the
focus on stem that's being promoted by
the dam right yeah a science technology
engineering and math and that's going to
they're going to focus that on kids in
grade school and that will give them an
opportunity for jobs in the 21st century
because science technology engineering
and math will be the foundation for for
good jobs in Korea I agree with one
additional letter a steam arts
creativity we have steam arts and
creativity arts I don't know we already
have that you have hearts we've been
cutting arts programs K through 12 we I
don't agree with you're confusing the
film industry right art yeah
you know twice as many students get
degrees in like the Dramatic Arts as
they do in the STEM fields we have to
stop this nonsense but but I'll tell you
it's stem is fundamental but you've got
to you got to bring that added value
you've got to bring that extra the
extras the ability to form new
connections you don't need to teach
creative in school I think your artists
are artists they will out weather
wherever they are I think it's yeah I
think I think you know it's a great
quote from Lincoln we're all born
originals but sadly too many of us die
copies life D genius isness it's like
heart my kids are incredibly talented
artistic expressive and open and all of
a sudden sense of schools which is all
about conformity takes that all away and
while I appreciate the stem we've got to
have that arts education we're
passionate about okay um Gavin how do
you remain so smart and good-looking at
the same time same guy the same time uh
another is there a car for you Monica's
there correlation between strong unions
and a strong middle class
hmm well I think the idea of wages and
the middle class is very important and
so unions in the past have fought for
higher wages and the the big issue now
is that corporations have too much power
and so the question becomes how do you
seize that power back we had a healthier
economy in my opinion decades ago when
again the employer base was fragmented
there were lots of small companies when
when your boss knows who you are they're
less likely to fire you a small auto
body shop is less likely to replace you
with a robot than GM because there's
some new technology so there's many
different ways to skin this cat a union
helps to push up wages and what I'm
arguing is that having more small
businesses again also helps to bring up
wages and that brings a healthier
economy but we used to have 35 percent
the country was belonged to a union and
now it's 7% and when you look at the
numbers also how the middle class is
shrinking aren't those or is that just a
coincidence I'm not saying it
necessarily is arisen but it seems like
there is a correlation
well we've given a lot of power to big
companies and it's if big companies have
this much power over us you do need
unions but at the same token I'll remind
you that big companies don't just make
these laws happen on their own there's
people in government that are complicit
50% of politicians now go into with the
revolving door into the private sector
it used to be 3% so I mean it's not like
someone's coming with a gun or like with
a knife and being like politician make
this happen
I mean you're complicit it's happening
together yes yeah well said okay let's
get high thank you everybody
Real Time with Bill Maher asked
villainous gases your questions right
after the show at HBO calm or on Twitter